so we're about 45 minutes into our
interview with kyle rittenhouse and the
picture that emerges is of a
working-class kid who sincerely believes
in america his community falls apart and
he tries his best to do the right thing
at a time when almost nobody else in the
community is trying to do the right
thing but he does
and in return for that the state under
political pressure throws him in prison
then the people who swear they will help
him take advantage of him
that's a lot
so what does he plan to do now now that
he's been acquitted
well here's that part of the interview
what do you think your life's going to
be like after this
i'm hoping i can live a quiet
stress-free life
and not and be free of any intimidation
or harassment and just go on with my
life as a normal 18 year old kid
attending college
so you're going to go to college i am in
college i'm a student at arizona state
university
what i mean are you going to go to
campus and
i i think i am i want to
it's a lot of things we have to look
into so i don't know for sure yet
but i do intend on going in campus and
pursuing a career in nursing
i may change it i've been looking into
law i may want to become a lawyer i
haven't completely decided yet
but i've been looking i want to be a
nurse so i've been doing the
prerequisites for that
interesting
do you think you can have that that you
can live peacefully in this country
unmolested
i hope so but i can't read the future
i'm hoping that people go back and
understand the facts and be like
watch the trial
watch the prosecutorial misconduct that
i believe happened
and realize that i was an innocent 17
year old who was violently attacked and
defended myself because she wanted to
clean graffiti and protect a car lot
and apparently
a lot of people on the left it's
criminal to want to protect your
community do you feel like your life's
been destroyed by this
i feel
my life has been extremely defamed by it
i don't think i would be able to go out
and get a job
and not have to deal with harassment but
i'm at a place now to where
i can i have to have
people with me because people want to
kill me just because i defended myself
and they're
they're too ignorant to look at the
facts of what happened
do you feel the threats
i do i see some of the threats some of
the things people say it's absolutely
sickening
has do are you confident that the
government will protect you from these
threats because that's of course the
government's job
i hope so but we all know how the fbi
works
yeah
i mean looking back
it's been
you know a year and a half less than
even
this is not the life that you planned
it is far from the life i planned this
is
this is something that
i wish never would have happened
but it did and we can't change that
but how it's been so how it polarized
how polarized it became is absolutely
sickening like
right or left
people using me for a cause that should
never have been used as a cause i read
that you're not going to stay in the
midwest
i'm not i'm going to find somewhere to
live before this i actually wanted to
move to naples florida and
then this happened
but i don't know where i'm going to go
i'm gonna go lay low and
live live my life and enjoy it
why are you so calm
i'm a naturally calm person i don't find
i find it to be a problem when people
are overreacting because things are out
of our control
so i try not to deal with that
i mean just for the believe me on the
inside i'm freaking out well you must be
i mean for the record were
you know you just got acquitted yeah i
mean like two days ago so that was the
first thing i noticed that you seem very
calm
you don't seem like someone who's just
been through uh
you know had his mind blown
yeah and the inside i'm freaking out but
the best thing you do you freak out
everybody else freaks out it's like a
chain reaction yes so the best thing i
can do is stay calm
do you feel like you've been watched
over
i believe god's been on my side through
the beginning
i would imagine you could watch the
whole trial
and then watch those 48 minutes and come
away thinking kyle rittenhouse is a
monster just the opposite actually as we
said this is a boy who sincerely
believed in the promises of america do
the right thing
be honest
worked hard to turn himself into the
police
their response they pepper sprayed him
he'd drive across state lines speaking
of to turn himself in to the police
it's an amazing story and it's a deeply
sad story for what it says not about him
but about the rest of us
we've got reactions tonight to the
interview we just did from judge jeanine
pierre we've also got behind the scenes
footage that we shot our producer shot
for our documentary series behind the
scenes at the rittenhouse trial that's
all next hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else